um can you give me any sort of insight
because I know a lot of people
you know have already gotten over the
fact that the black hippie album allures
is gone came and went you know yeah uh
but how many songs were if any were set
aside for this this detox of a dream
that we all had
it could be zero it could be three I
don't know how many how many like how
many records were like conservatively
like okay the if we do this black hippie
thing this is this is in that folder on
that hard drive well that's what I'm
gonna say that's why I say again we did
more with less
so you know I don't wanna
you know
yeah but [ __ ] why I can't be man I'm I'm
I'm the best rapper out of all the
[ __ ] Can't Rap with me you know
I mean
no no we do know Q can out golf you
though absolutely yeah that's that's
been that's been proven right yeah he's
a uh he's a savant on that golf course
yeah Jesus Christ does he ever have you
like gone like actually Quincy Woods
have you been golfing with him no not
yet yeah he he said I'd be I'd I'd with
your vision situation I'd waste time I
was gonna say with your vision situation
yeah is you going golfing the safest
thing
I mean I know I know you're not blind
blind but like I mean to say this it's
not a safety issue he just was like bro
you be holding us up
I'm not gonna have you out there we
trying to you know what I mean like he's
like a [ __ ] Pro now yeah he's really
he really does that [ __ ] so that that's
just the whole thing but like you know
I'm sure I get out there just I've never
like been on an actual Golf Course have
you been to Topgolf I went to that's
where I'm you saw me on top so it was
cool Top Golf is cool but I'm saying I
one day I want to like go on an actual
golf course yeah in the cars have some
beers you know shoot the [ __ ] meet the
meet the rich people
you know shoot this [ __ ] be the ritual
you know what I'm saying that's great
you feel me uh join a country club you
know I want to do the whole thing I want
to do the whole dance man give me a nice
omelette you know those country clubs
are expensive that's what I'm saying man
go give me a 50
omelette you know I feel like uh enjoy
life